I read some I think it was a quote you
said once that it was Ted Turner who
told you you don't make friends after
your 60s and you have completely proven
him wrong yeah he also said you don't
change after 60. and I said I think I
think you're in big trouble if you don't
change after 60. right yeah I mean 60 is
when you start where you're I'm a few
months shy of becoming 60. yeah well 60
in the way I look at it is the beginning
of your third act yeah and in order to
do a good third Act
in order to know how to go forward in
your third act you have to know where
you've been so you have to spend a lot
of time thinking about the first two
acts and even more important your
parents why are they the way they are
yeah were they are your parents my
parents are my dad is 94 my mom is 91.
uh-huh and they're out in the clubs
every night
how long have they been married I think
uh wow good lord they're the only people
that got married it's a very I think at
the very close of the Civil War
um I uh I mean I I wish I could tell you
exactly but I want to say it was 1958
okay so they've only been married to
each other oh yes yeah yeah that was it
that's how strict Irish Catholics you
marry and then that is yeah no matter
what there were many times I'm still
trying to get my mom to divorce my dad
um I call them I call her every day and
say it's time go but uh she's sticking
it out you're trying to get her on the
apps
she keeps showing the wrong way that's
what's ruining it yeah we're finding out
I mean you know fight you're lucky that
they're still alive yes I am very lucky
well the mine were gone by the time I
started my sixth my third act but
um finding out why they are the way they
are how were their parents what were
your grandparents like how did they
treat you know yeah what you end up when
it's called doing a Life review and you
end up realizing that whatever was
up had nothing to do with you
yeah yeah you know I turned my Life
review Into My memoir
and in the course of doing it I
discovered why my mother was the way she
was and it had nothing to do with me had
to do with Early Childhood sexual abuse
and so I could forgive yeah you know and
that's such a beautiful thing I think
it's one out of every four women in this
country have experienced sexual abuse
and it's interesting to try to
tease that out if that's part of your
family history which means that you have
to interview your parents separately I
think the other thing too is
um there was such a reticence about
talking about anything I mean I come
from a very Irish Catholic culture as
you can imagine and it's the same thing
you unpleasant things are not discussed
you don't talk about them so laughter is
allowed uh and and food is allowed sex
is discouraged and talking about
anything that might hurt somebody's
feelings is discouraged so you get this
strange ecosystem sometimes and I'm just
not my family is all so much I just
watched the Banshees events yeah I was
going to ask you I watched the Banshees
of Anna Sharon you identified and and
it's crazy it's takes place in you know
I think 1920 or something and it it's on
this island and it's in Ireland and I
grew up in uh Boston and my parents are
very educated people and I watch that
movie with miniature donkeys and people
cutting off their fingers and absolute
Madness and and not just me but other
Irish people that I know other Irish
Americans I know go oh yeah that makes
sense because we're an insular crazy
people with a Gift of Gab and we can be
quite funny uh and we get quite
depressed but uh we come from this
island and there's stuff in our DNA
that's batshit crazy yeah I was married
to one my second husband Irish Catholic
how'd that go
beautifully and fabulously for much of
the time and I'm really really grateful
and we named our son Troy O'Donovan oh
there you go that's too Irish that's a
very Irish name the Garrison it'll
either be a playwright or a bartender
he's an actor those are the only two
choices I'm afraid